our global presence allows us to offer
our Pittsburgh great pittsburgh-based
students a global experience which is
really important in this day and age of
what we call a flat world you learn how
to collaborate with other people that
specifically and most importantly with
people from other countries make it work
with one another and you just learn so
much off of these other people on the
diversity of everyone it's just
everybody has different backgrounds to
actually be sitting in the classroom
filled with students from Greece filled
with students from Japan I think it was
something it just makes things more
interactive the ini has focused very
much on helping provide all the students
with everything we need nice to not have
to worry about the money and plus you
know you have it you have this program
that structured to basically you know
get you an internship and get you a job
I like the fact that we had our own
computers we had offices that made it
useful for studying and for group
activities and working with other
students if you kind of understood the
material but you wanted to review over a
certain section you could go on to
blackboard use that and then also they
had like the group chat on there the
yoga community we have a student asked
questions one important aspect of our
student body is also the great social
background students oftentimes meet in
groups and have a lot of fun outside the
classroom as well we need actually the
women at ia it's basically an
organization that is trying to foster
the role of women in computer science
and what it does is you know we have a
lot of social events we have a lot of
academic event I think it's nice to be
in a cluster your first year because you
know you're kind of in this small group
of people that are always around each
other always getting work done so you
know it's nice just because you can make
friends with those people we working
groups and we like enjoy like their
passion for for for the topics together
you will be surrounded by people by good
people the two years that I've had at
the ina have been probably the two best
years of my life
you know you know the relationships that
have me do the friends that I've made
here I'm going to change them you know
for a lifetime